It has been heralded alternately as a
Google killer and the most important
general purpose technology since the
wheel or fire Chuck Beattie is an A.I.
powered chat bot whose answers honestly
feel human.
But the very feature that makes it seem
almost magical.
Also poses a colossal problem because we
don't really know where its answers are
coming from.
Let's start with the basics chart.
GDP is built by opening by a company
that's backed by Microsoft and it's more
or less free for anyone to use.
It works by ingesting hundreds of
gigabytes of tax data on which it is
then trains to generate human like
responses.
It's pretty mind blowing.
This is an essay that it wrote about
Romeo and Juliet.
This is some software code.
It could even generate jokes that are
almost funny.
Crucially, it works differently from
Google.
It doesn't just quote sources verbatim
and present it to you.
Instead, it works much the way human
words.
If I've taken an undergraduate course
in, say, critical theory and someone
asked me about the German sociologist
Tailed or Adorno, I would dig into the
recesses of my memory and cough up an
answer.
I might not necessarily know the exact
source of that answer.
Some book or lecture from more than a
decade ago.
Frankly, my answer might not be entirely
accurate.
Chapter BPT is similar.
It doesn't cite a source.
The way that a responsible journalist or
academic would Google for all of its
justifiable criticism for the way that
it scrapes data from other web sites and
presents them on its own platforms does
at least cite the source.
Same with Wikipedia.
If you read an article that feels a
little bit sketchy, you can click
through the source and find for yourself
whether you think it is accurate and
beyond.
Just checking the veracity of any
information.
The source itself doesn't get any
credit.
There might be less incentive to post
things online if it's just being scraped
by some A.I.
algorithm.
This is a bigger issue with A.I.
as a whole.
The very nature of deep learning is such
that often the system itself doesn't
know the source of the information that
is presented.
Chuck TVT is just a beta for the moment.
Maybe some of these issues can be fixed,
but that's also why it's worth
discussing them right now.